there's something indecent about getting
a video game for free try to really be
allowed to have so much fun without
shelling out a dime aren't I taking food
from a developer's mouth these are the
thoughts that go through my head before
I download a game and after well I'm too
focused on having fun to care about
what's going on behind the scenes just
like last month's there are two free
games / Sony platform for those who
subscribe to PlayStation Plus and the
highlight is none other than towerfall
ascension you may remember earlier this
year when some people proclaim that the
best tefal game on March 11th was
ascension instead of that heavily hyped
titanfall and you know what they were
spot-on if you have a couple of friends
and a hankering for arrow genocide look
no further than this competitive darling
the other ps4 game is Strider now this
is a modern revamp of the sword slashing
adventure from years ago and it's ninja
riffic to coin a terrible word but
here's a little backstory that may
interest you amazon that omnipresent
online retailer was so taken by double
helixes of work on Strider and killer
instinct that they purchased them don't
you want to see where all the fuss is
about let's just go back one generation
to the ps3 there's in time when killing
zombies meant lining up a brutal head
shop and then Along Came dead space when
we realized how fun eviscerating other
body parts could be well dead space 3
took that idea one step further
following from another dead themed game
dead rising in dead space 3 you could
construct your own instruments of death
so even though this might be the last
game in the franchise it's still worth
playing especially for free vessel well
I'm not quite as interested in vessel
sure it's a puzzle platformer which
seemed to dominate my free time but
there's just saying that kept me from
enjoying this water-themed adventure I
always felt slightly lost fumbling from
one location to another and lucky my way
to solutions a lot of people did enjoy
those maybe I'm just wrong finally we
move on to the Vita sure not many people
own this wonderful system but that's not
for lack of excellent game
maura Massa reverses the best of the two
being given away this smooth stylish
adventure debuted which seems like a
decade ago on the week and looks and
plays better than ever in this update
it's certainly one to clear some time
for and the last game is doki-doki
universe this is a weird one if you
couldn't tell from the name it's made by
the guy who made pogge a man Earl so you
know it's funny and has this quirky
personality test that appeared a little
too deeply into my soul that wraps up
July's releases if you're like me you're
impressed by how many great games there
are and slightly disappointed they
already got so many oh well I'm always
letting others are going to discover
something special